y
[Música]
con agua más sana en cualquier caso
estamos infelices miren como quemaron el
puesto de control estamos en el puente
del turia
en el noreste de la república
democrática del congo los rebeldes de
las fuerzas democráticas aliadas las pda
han ampliado sus acciones a la provincia
de ituri los días 10 y 11 de abril
alrededor de 30 personas fueron
asesinadas por este grupo islamista de
origen ugandés muy cerca de la ciudad de
comanda los atentados fueron
reivindicados con fotos por la
organización de estado islámico a la que
las ff.aa prometieron lealtad nuestro
observador que pidió permanecer en el
anonimato trabaja en el sector agrícola
y se encontraban muy cerca del lugar de
los atentados y tuvo que trasladarse a
otros pueblos cercanos con otros cientos
de habitantes locales
la acción de ser bl o sea para las
acciones de estos rebeldes comenzaron el
8 de abril
cuando se informó de su presencia en un
pueblo de los alrededores de comanda
pase la noche allá un poco rible porque
hubo disparos
y como se puso peor salimos huyendo
cantet
hay a la gente sólo vivía con artículos
domésticos como jazz
y los demás llevaban colchones y algo de
ropa
y
reina una especie de sicosis entre la
población
las imágenes enviadas a nuestra
redacción muestran los cuerpos que
fueron encontrados al borde de la
carretera en un pueblo muy cercano a la
ciudad de comanda el pasado 11 de abril
nuestro observador tomó estas fotos de
los pueblos devastados por los rebeldes
teme que los ataques y también el
desplazamiento de las personas que
trabajan en el sector agrícola afecten
el suministro de alimentos a la ciudad
de bonn ya que es la capital de la
provincia de ituri
entre noviembre y diciembre o ataques de
las que te vea en la parte sur del tour
y lg comanda ven este era un eje muy
importante para la ciudad de junio ya
que suministra más productos del campo
carbón vegetal
luego el eje que seguía siendo muy
importante era el de comanda man base y
ahora después de los atentados aquí aquí
el eje está cortado porque ya uno no
puede dedicarse a sus actividades
rurales por miedo a ser decapitado
asesinado por estos rebeldes de la ader
entiendo que es una política de invasión
que poco a poco se está imponiendo en
las olas
según una organización congoleña de los
derechos humanos los ataques continuaron
en ituri ocasionando la muerte de al
menos 85 personas en 10 días a mediados
del pasado mes de abril desde el 2013 al
menos 6.000 personas han sido asesinadas
por las pda
para luchar contra los rebeldes las
provincias de kivú del norte en ituri
que están asediadas desde mayo del 2021
lanzaron el pasado mes de noviembre una
operación militar conjunta con uganda
esta es mi hija estamos camino a la
muerte nos están llevando a riad para
deportar nos del país
esta mujer se llama buen genio abu la
ella es un gurú y se grabó con su hija
tras ser detenida por las autoridades
sauditas llegó a arabia saudita desde
turquía país en donde vivían otros dos
uigures son el ex marido de esta mujer y
un amigo que permanecen detenidos
también en arabia saudita desde
noviembre del 2020 según diferentes ong
estos cuatro ciudadanos uigures corren
ahora el riesgo de ser deportados a
china un país al que se le acusa de
aplicar una política represiva hacia
esta minoría musulmana
hay una patrulla de policía delante y
otra detrás
abdul de hui ayub es un exiliado en
noruega que lleva casi dos años en
contacto con esta mujer ya han
documentado varios casos de extradición
de uigures de arabia saudita a china y
trata de disuadir a aquellos que desean
hacer la peregrinación a la ciudad
sagrada de la meca
dos meses antes se sentó y envió
mensajes y esos vídeos de que estaba en
peligro
y que estaba a punto de ser deportada en
ese momento le dije estás en peligro en
arabia saudita tienes que irte
tiene lo único que puedo hacer es
compartir esta información con
organizaciones de derechos humanos y
periodistas
y hasta ahora no he salvado a ningún
guild
los uigures se manifestaron contra esta
situación justo enfrente de la sede de
la embajada de arabia saudita en la
ciudad de washington en eeuu
a ti
el pasado 18 de abril la madre y la hija
seguían todavía en riad en arabia
saudita la situación de los dos hombres
es más difícil de determinar según
nuestro observador 8 wilbur es que han
sido expulsados de arabia saudita a
china pero ninguna de estas expulsiones
fue resultado de un acuerdo oficial
entre los dos países por lo que sigue
siendo muy difícil documentar este
fenómeno con precisión y broward
todos los figure es de 7 a 70 años saben
dónde queda la meca cuando restan cinco
veces se dirigen hacia la meca y para
ellos la meca es el lugar más seguro del
mundo llamamos a la meca casa de ala
y la gente se siente segura porque es la
casa de ala
pero estos uigures fueron detenidos en
la casa de ala y deportados a la casa
del mal
es todo por esta semana en los
observadores de france 24 recuerden que
si ustedes quieren comunicarse con la
producción del programa nuestros datos
de contacto aparecen en sus pantallas
queremos agradecer a la feria
internacional del libro de la ciudad de
bogotá por haber sido nuestra locación
el día de hoy nosotros nos vemos la
próxima semana hasta entonces